these are the trends I see in society
it's becoming more materialistic and
it's so funny because I hear women say
again and again and again they can't
afford children yet they find a way to
afford a fifty thousand dollar wedding a
twenty thousand dollar wedding and it's
becoming even though marriage really is
a way for people to trans to basically
have generational wealth right if people
get married and stay married that's a
way to have generational wealth but it's
so interesting because I was thinking
about how in society we really have a
society where men are slaving away for
women because what happens is men pay
over a hundred thousand dollars more in
tax in their lifetime than women so men
are essentially working their lives to
give money to women